moving on
our main story tonight concerns jury
duty hey summons for which is one of the
things you least want to find in the
mail aside from maybe
a bill or a human toe and please a pinky
call me when you're serious enough to
send a middle piggy then maybe we'll
talk business
complaining about jury duty has long
been a beloved american pastime
just watch this call us to a 90s local
tv show delights the host with his
whining
they put us down in this holding pen
they call it the jury assembly room
yeah the jury the j-a-r the jar they
stick you in this jar
with like three or 300 other people for
a whole week
oh man and i figure it's like being in
jail only jealous a whole lot better
because joe's a lot cleaner and has
much better lighting oh and we have to
pay for our own food and we don't get to
go outside we don't get free hbo
we don't get to talk as much and we
don't get health care and we don't get
conjugal visits you don't get any of
that stuff don't get any of that
now he's actually right you don't get
conjugal visits while waiting to be
called at jury duty although judging
from that call
being at jury duty isn't that cool as
primary obstacle in that department
as for not getting hbo i don't know what
he's complaining about there they don't
even give me free hbo and i'm actively
ruining it
now that man greg was a regular caller
to that show and i know that because
we got curious about him after watching
that clip and it turns out
he's a lot for example greg has a
website where you can find classic
gregasms like
environmentalism is evil or the baptists
are the pin in the homo grenade
incidentally greg isms isn't even a term
i made up it's an actual section of his
website
we can honestly spend the rest of this
show on greg but sadly
we do have to move on because the
important thing about jury duty is you
know what just one more thing about greg
he's been tweeting it's almost time to
have a great hashtag weekend everyone
who's with me
every friday for the last very many
fridays and read the room greg no one
has great hashtag weekends anymore we're
all sitting at home watching the days
blur together in a miserable
hashtag time soup but while it might
sound cliche
serving on a jury really is an essential
civic duty
the right to a trial by an impartial
jury of your peers
is enshrined in the sixth amendment of
the constitution but the truth is
while your peers are supposed to be
chosen from a fair cross-section of
society
people of color are routinely excluded
according to a study of 14 federal
district courts
under representation of the latino and
african-american populations is
ubiquitous
which is a problem with huge
implications for juries
this social psychologist staged mock
cases where some juries were all white
and others were racially diverse and
found that the diverse ones
operated more fairly and deliberated
more comprehensively
in this study they they raised more
facts from the trial they discuss a
broader range of information
they discuss the information more
accurately actually in discussing the
facts of the case
they're more willing to have
uncomfortable conversations about
controversial issues like those
involving race and racial profiling
yeah it turns out juries are sort of
like presidents of the spokane
washington chapter of the naacp
when they're entirely white things tend
to go south fast
and this is reflected in the real world
researchers who examined felony trials
in florida found juries formed from all
white pools
convict black defendants a full 16
percentage points more often
than they do white defenders but that
gap in conviction rate is entirely
eliminated
when the pool includes at least one
black member and that's one of those
facts that he probably assumed was
true even though you wish it wasn't like
the fact that dogs don't really enjoy
music
or that sean penn's new wife is a year
younger than his daughter
so tonight let's take a look at why
juries are so often unrepresentative
and what we can do about it and the
whole process starts with what's called
a jury wheel a pool of potential jurors
in a community it used to be
an actual wheel and for many years black
people were explicitly excluded from
them and even after the civil rights act
of 1875
said you couldn't discriminate against
jurors based on race
many officials would still find ways to
remove them like by printing their names
on different colour paper
so they could be avoided during the
supposedly random drawings and while
thankfully
that doesn't happen anymore our current
system has many flaws
that can end up having a similar result
for instance nowadays jury wheels are
often
computerized lists gathered from voter
registration and driver's license
records but
there's a big problem there as this
public defender in new orleans
explains not everybody's registered to
vote and not everybody owns a car
you know has a driver's license the
problem is when we use voter
registration or dmv records we're
probably excluding around 35 percent of
new orleans
right 35 of people are excluded there
and being registered to vote and owning
a car doesn't affect whether you're
qualified to serve on a jury it just
affects
how much money you probably spend on
bumper stickers bumper stickers
think of them as traffic twitter that's
not a compliment
and the exclusions don't stop there most
states ban people with felony
convictions
and withdraw pay being incredibly low
lower income people
can be unable to afford to take part
both of which disproportionately exclude
people of color so inherently the system
is already biased
and that's before you even get into the
mistakes that jury summoning systems can
make which
to be fair can sometimes be pretty fun
i got jerry duty i said what's jerry
duty
summon for jerry jury service
if you're picked then you go up to the
judge and then you say if they're
guilty or not guilty yeah jacob
got jerry duty and while i can't believe
he found casey anthony not guilty that's
what he and his gerry decided
and we just need to live with that but
some errors are significantly less fun
for instance in connecticut it emerged
that their jury selection computer
program had accidentally read the d
in hartford to mean deceased so for
nearly three years
it never summoned anyone from hartford
or indeed new britain the second largest
city in that district because
their list of names had been
accidentally misplaced and was never
entered into the program and the thing
is
those two missing cities accounted for
of african americans in the district and
of the hispanic population which is
horrible
because if you're going to forget a town
in connecticut why not forget danbury
because
and this is true dan berry from its
charming railway museum to its historic
half stone castle
danbury connecticut can eat my whole ass
i know exactly three things about
danbury
usa today ranked it the second best city
to live in in 2015
it was once the center of the american
hat industry and if you're from there
you've got a standing invite to come get
a thrashing from john oliver
children included you now that
harford error was made by the
government's own system but many
courts actually contract out their jury
selection to companies like these
who promise to run the process cheaper
and more effectively but private
companies
can be surprisingly unreliable take what
happened outside tulsa oklahoma where a
black man was tried by an all-white
jewelry
drawn from a pool of 200 jurors without
a single black person
in it after the company handling jury
selection accidentally excluded zip
codes
when 90 of its black residents lived
then there's allen county indiana where
this company had a system that was
programmed to work
through an alphabetical list of
townships and stop when it reached 10
000 names unfortunately it turned out 75
of african americans in that county
happen to live in wayne
township towards the end of the alphabet
meaning they had roughly half the chance
of being included on a jury
than a truly random system would have
produced so yet again
alphabetization fails us i've said this
for years
it's an abc supremacist system that
disrespects
the better end of the alphabet because
think about it z
has got all the hotties zayn zoe
zendaya zac efron and of course zonkeys
half donkey half zebra all
sex now the extent of that indiana era
only emerged when a man who'd been
convicted there
sued over the makeup of his jury and his
lawyer pointed out to the state supreme
court
just how lax the design process had been
it's not a glitch
it's not a glitch or a computer bug it's
programming determinations these were
codes these were determinations that the
programmer
put into the program he didn't it didn't
some gargles virus come and
make the program go bad it was bad
because he made these decisions and
easily they could have been programmed
another way this was a part-time
college student that's true that
county's jury system was originally
designed by a college student
whose previous job incidentally had been
working at a head shop
and look there are plenty of jobs that
people with headshot experience are
qualified to do for instance
cleaning bong resin off an ikea couch
cushion or going on a late night snack
run to 7-eleven and only getting 40
of what everyone asked for i'm just not
sure that programming a county's
official jury list
is one of those jobs and whether the
errors in these programs were deliberate
or just careless the result is the same
and i'd love to tell you mistakes like
these are rare but the truth is
no one knows how common they are we only
know about the examples that i've
mentioned so far because of lawsuits
that took
years private vendors often won't reveal
details about their systems claiming
their algorithms are a trade secret
and 39 out of 50 states provide
no public access to jury data so
your court system might have a massive
problem and until a nine-year-old shows
up for a murder trial
no one would have any idea and all of
this is before
jurors even show up for selection at
which point things can get
even worse because prosecutors tend to
exclude black jurors
sometimes out of implicit bias but
sometimes out of a bias that is pretty
explicit just watch this philadelphia
d.a addressing a room full of
prosecutors
in a leaked 1980s training video
explaining which jurors
they might want to avoid another factor
i'll tell you if
you know in in selecting blacks again
you don't want the real educated ones
again it's this goes across the board of
all races you don't want smart people
uh and again but if you if
you're sitting down and you're going to
take blacks you want older blacks in my
experience black
women young black women are very bad uh
there's an antagonism i guess maybe
because they're downtrodden on two
respects they've got two minorities
they're women and they're blacks and
so they're downtrodden two areas and
they somehow uh want to take it out on
somebody and you don't want it to be you
okay first any white people who use the
word black as a noun
and not an adjective are pretty
suspicious throw in that mustache and
suddenly it feels like a spike lee
period piece
and even putting aside the bigotry there
the only time it's acceptable to say
we don't want smart people is in a
training manual for selling lularoe
because if your business model is sell
5000 ugly leggings on facebook to the
people who hated you in high school then
yeah
you're gonna want to weed out the smart
people now
we reached out to that prosecutor who
was very upset saying
everyone has tried to somehow make this
racist even though he agreed that
the best jury is by racial something
slightly undercut by the fact that a
you just heard him say young black women
are very bad
and b a later review of felony cases
that he tried
found he'd removed black jurors at such
a high rate the odds of it happening by
chance
were won in a quadrillion and that guy
is not a one-off
recent studies in north carolina and
louisiana found prosecutors
striking black jurors at twice and three
times the rate
of white jurors and if you're wondering
how they were able to do that
it's probably worth knowing that in a
trial lawyers have two ways
to remove jurors the first is a
so-called challenge for
course that's where they can show that a
juror can't be impartial because of some
connection to the trial or
because they were somehow unfit to serve
the second
is a peremptory challenge where they can
remove a limited number of jurors
with no explanation although since a
1986 supreme court ruling
they can't exclude jurors purely based
on race
it's something that this hln host
explains in a borderline aggressively
literal way
what happens is the prosecution and
defense each have 10
jurors each that they can reject for any
reason at all or for no reason
unless they believe the other side
is playing the race card and they can
then
challenge that preemptory challenge okay
i've got a lot of questions and
absolutely none of them are about
preemptory challenges
first why use the loaded term playing
the race card at all
uh second why imply it means acting in a
racist fashion
when it doesn't but most importantly how
long did that man walk around with that
race card in his suit pocket
was it just for the show or does he
always walk around with it on the off
chance that he has to explain peremptory
challenges to someone and if so
does he ever go to pay for something
accidentally pull out his race card and
then say oops
that's not my wallet that's my race card
to the utter bewilderment of the cashier
also
how did he get that card did he make it
himself because that'd be weird but it
might actually be weirder if he'd ask
someone else to make it for him that
would mean he'd ask the producer hey
can you make me a race card for my
segment on jury selection to which she
probably said
what do you mean and he said you know
like a physical card that says
race card on it and then the producer
said why and he said because i'm trying
to explain lawyers playing the race card
when striking jurors which the producer
said but
can't you just say the phrase playing
the race card or you know
not actually say it at all and he said
absolutely not
so a production assistant then had to
spend 20 minutes printing the words race
card
on a red card is that how it came to
exist and what happened to it after the
show did he throw it away
or did he put it on his desk just in
case he ever needed it again and if so
did someone ever walk by and say hey
what the is that to which you
replied oh that's just my race card as
if that's a normal thing to say or to
have and finally and i know this isn't
the most important thing
why does it say race card on it it's
already a card shouldn't it just say
race
because isn't the thing he's actually
holding up there technically a race card
card and if so what the does that
mean i've got so many questions about
this
and i know we don't have time but i
guess my broader point is there are two
ways for lawyers to strike jurors and
hln
is a deeply weird television network but
what the supreme court said
that you can't strike jurors based on
race it turns out
that's a pretty easy rule to get around
all you have to do is just
come up with some reason other than race
to strike a juror and then do it anyway
remember that lawyer that you saw
earlier he was speaking after
that ruling was handed down and was
openly instructing prosecutors
on how not to get caught let's say you
strike three blacks to start with
first three people and then it's like
the defense attorney makes an objection
saying that you're striking black
well you're not going to be able to go
back and say oh yeah make something up
about why he did it
write it down right then and there so
sometimes under that line you may want
to ask more questions of those people so
it gives you more ammunition to
making articulable reason as to why
you're striking them and not for race
wow it's pretty bizarre to see a
government official so flagrantly
teaching people how to do something
illegal
it's like if how to get away with murder
was an educational series where viola
davis explains how to literally get
away with murder which he'd absolutely
crush by the way
i'd gladly watch multiple seasons of her
describing in vivid detail how to
dismember a corpse and dissolve the body
parts in acid
and look to this day prosecutors use a
wide variety of reasons to
strike black jurors some of which
are just flat out ridiculous like saying
jurors were
too young too old single divorced
religious or not religious
lived in a poor part of town had a
hyphenated last name
displayed bad posture or was sullen
disrespectful or talkative in fact
just listen to this public defender
describe a juror strike that he once saw
i had a juror an african-american woman
who was actually excluded
because she was wearing what's called a
puffy coat yeah
she was excluded for wearing a puffy
coat
and a jacket should never be an
acceptable reason to exclude someone
from a jury unless
it's the one that post malone wore to
the american music awards he looks like
he's supposed to jump out of a cake at a
mariachi themed gender reveal party
and if you want to see the lengths to
which prosecutors are willing to go
just look at the multiple murder trials
of curtis flowers in mississippi
his case made it all the way to the
supreme court which decided that his
prosecutor
had repeatedly and blatantly tried to
whitewash the jury and that opinion
was written by maybe the last justice
you'd expect
justice brett kavanaugh wrote that a
white mississippi prosecutor's goal
was to have an all-white jury decide the
fate of an african-american man accused
of murder which
is unconstitutional the court's newest
justice said that district attorney doug
evans waged a relentless determined
effort to rid the jury of black
individuals it was curtis flowers sixth
trial for the same quadruple murder
kavanaugh pointed to a pattern noting
that evans had removed 41 of the 42
prospective black jurors
over the six trials 41 of 42 jurors
you know you're doing something wrong
when it's so flagrant even brett
kavanaugh has a problem with it a man
who's done exactly two good things in
his life
this decision and making it acceptable
to spend your entire job interview
screaming and crying
and it wasn't just how often that
prosecutor struck black jurors it's how
blatantly he did it
because while on average he asked the
whites jurors who were seated
one question he asked the black jurors
he struck
29 and how do you ask anyone
that many questions about anything that
is too many even for a first date who's
desperately trying to keep the
conversation going
let's see i've asked about where you
grew up what you do for work whether you
like your job whether you have any
siblings whether your siblings are older
or younger what you'd like to do for fun
what kind of music you like what else is
there
do you like rakes and a prospective
juror in one of curtis flowers trials
felt pretty clear about why she'd been
struck
they just told us they didn't need us i
think they might have assumed that
because i was black that i was going to
agree with that he was innocent just by
the color of his skin but i actually
would have listened to the evidence and
had an open ear i actually was looking
forward to serving
look it is ridiculous to assume that a
juror will be biased
just because the defendant is the same
race of course a black person can be
impartial when the defendant is black in
the same way that i could be impartial
if the defendant was an
owl to suggest otherwise is extremely
insulting not just to myself
but to all owls and these decisions have
consequences
curtis flowers spent 20 years on death
row and is currently out on bail
awaiting a potential
seventh trial so taken all together it's
pretty clear that from how we decide who
serves to how the list is administered
through who we let lawyers select we are
making a mockery of the phrase
a jury of your peers because who exactly
is the you
there the defendant's peers or the
prosecutor's peers
that's a pretty big difference and as
we've seen
the impact of having people in a jury
room who can speak to what being black
in america is like and
how that might affect your relationship
with law enforcement can be hugely
beneficial
and yes that might make a prosecutor's
job a bit more difficult but the role of
a court
is not to make it easy by having
cases heard by only a group of white
people
or to use the proper collective noun for
that a whole foods
i'm serious try in a sentence look at
that gaggle of geese
flying over that whole foods of abigails
so how do we fix this well there are
four basic steps we could take
one broaden jury list so they don't
exclude large sections of the community
some have suggested using income tax
lists for instance to
make that data public so we can see if
there were errors in compiling potential
jurors
three increase juror pay so that people
who miss work don't suffer financial
hardship and finally
reform the process behind preemptory
challenges to make it more
practically difficult to strike jurors
by race and while yes
this is a lot of work it is worth it
because as we have discussed before on
this show
every gear in the criminal justice
system is unfairly biased against people
of color
from policing to bail to the shortage of
public defenders to punitive sentencing
to incarceration
to re-entry from prison and this is yet
another to add to that depressing list
because right now too often our current
system would systematically weed out a
qualified person who actually wants to
serve
and leave in someone who aggressively
doesn't because he can't watch hbo and
the jewelry box
you